I guess just to start off what were you
like as a child were you as terrorizing
his movie yeah that was a pain in the
ass as a kid I'm not gonna lie dia I was
difficult I was argumentative for sure
how did your parents keep you in line a
lot of bribery and a lot of just letting
me kind of go do whatever crazy things I
wanted to do I think did you use those
tips when you were when you adopted no I
tried to go exactly opposite I tried to
parent my kids in the way that I would
not have wanted to be parented I don't
even know what that is no I know I think
I had really wonderful parents and I
learned a lot from them but I you know I
also learned from some of their mistakes
there were certain things that I knew I
was playing my parents so when I became
a dad I was like all right I'm ahead of
you guys on some of the stuff what did
you play my Matt well you know - I'm
trying to think of like a specific
example but when you're arguing to get a
certain toy or to go to a certain place
or whatever there's just certain
techniques you have kids no no okay
you'll find out there are certain
techniques that you know kind of a go-to
toolbox that I used it cuz I would just
hammer away at my parents so I try not
to let my kids kind of like bulldoze me
the way that I bulldoze my parents
sometimes no I feel like I did the same
thing to my parents yeah that's good for
me how much of this film is sort of
based on your own sort of real life you
know experiences it's what is that
balance it's hard to kind of put a
percentage on it but emotionally I feel
every emotion in the movie story-wise
it was inspired by my own story but also
the stories of several other real
adoptive families that I met either
along the way or in my research process
so virtually everything that happens in
the movie you could trace back to
somebody's real story and all of the
emotions that are experienced in the
movie you can trace back to my own well
were those stories that you tell other
families well you know for example
there's a there's a scene where where
Lizzy and where Rose burns character
finally makes a really deep connection
with Lizzy when she's able to brush her
hair and Lizzy feels like her it
frightens her that somebody is getting
close to her that way and the hairbrush
winds up in the toilet and that scene
was conveyed to me by a social worker
who had worked with a real family that
it had that exact thing happens so we
had heard so many wonderful stories to
boil them all down and I wanted to I
wanted to touch on as many different
aspects of this story as I could
so really boiling all these stories down
to two hours was tough as your own
family seen the movie yet oh yeah oh is
that what was their reaction well
they've been living with it for a long
time because I've been talking about it
I've been so obsessed with it for so
long
and I think when they finally saw it
they were really excited because they
saw it with an audience and they were
seeing how the audience was reacting to
it and it was pretty overwhelming so I
think they were pretty knocked out that
are because they to them to my kids we
just feel like a pretty normal boring
family at this point I think they were
pretty knocked out that people were
responding that overwhelmingly to it
is it nervous to show them a movie
that's basically about them is that well
it was funny there's a part in the movie
where Mark and Rose are really
frustrated with the kids and they're
talking about how they can't stand
having them in the house talking not to
the kids but one another and me and my
wife were watching that scene with our
kids and they said did you say stuff
like that about us and I said no no we
said way worse stuff than that about you
guys kids are pretty secure
you